Speaker 1: In the latest example of Ron DeSantis
showing he's simply not ready for prime time and
certainly not in a position to actually win a
Republican primary, which he may very well enter.
There are now rumors that he will announce in the
next week or so. Ron DeSantis was asked yesterday,
did Trump lose in 2020? Can you just say like
Trump lost? There wasn't all this fraud that
Donald Trump talked about and DeSantis weasels
out and refuses to actually answer the question,
instead talking about how there is a culture of
losing in the Republican Party and blah, blah,
blah, blah. This is not a strategy that
is going to win him the primary. I will
explain why after we look at the clip.
Listen to this. Standing for absolutely
nothing. That should be Ron Desantis's
campaign motto. You said during an event.
Speaker 2: In Iowa over the
weekend that the GOP needs to start
a culture of losing. You acknowledge the
Trump loss and the one. All he talks about.
When I look at the last however many election
cycles, 2018, we lost the House. We lost the
Senate. 2020 Biden becomes President.
Go. Excuse me. We lost the Senate in
2020. Biden becomes president and it's done
a huge amount of damage, very unpopular in
2022. And we are supposed to have this big red
wave. And other than like Florida and Iowa,
I didn't see a red wave across this country.
And so I think the party has developed
a culture of losing. I think that there's
not accountability. And I think in Florida,
we really showed what it takes to not just win.
Speaker 1: The question was, did Trump lose?
These people are these are not serious.
Speaker 2: People win big and then deliver
big. And ultimately, when you're doing all
this, what results are you producing for
people? That's really what matters. You
can sit there and talk about cable news,
social media, all these other things.
Speaker 1: That's not what the reporter
was talking about. The reporter
just said, Did Trump lose.
Speaker 2: Things that that people are
fixated on? And for me, it's like, okay,
what's that true? North You obviously got to win,
otherwise you don't get a ticket to the dance.
Speaker 1: And did. TRUMP When you're
not answering the questions, sir.
Speaker 2: Once you do that, how are you
going to be able to actually bring about big
change to make people's lives better next year?
Speaker 1: Next year? This is not going to cut it,
my friends. This this is wishy washy, weak
nonsense. DeSantis is probably afraid of
alienating the loyal Trump base. And the loyal
Trump base still seems to believe the obvious lie.
The obvious lie that Trump lost jobs, right?
The obvious lie that Trump won in 2020. They
are unable to accept the reality that their guy
simply didn't win. And so DeSantis is calculating,
Well, I can't just say, yeah, Trump lost and he
should accept it because they might need some of
those supporters. But the problem is that when
you're asked Did Trump lose and you rant for 80
seconds about the midterms and who the hell
knows what else you alienate. Every American
who's sick and tired of the Trump lie that
he actually won in 2020, which is, of course,
almost every Democrat, the vast majority of
independents and many Republicans as well,
although certainly not all. So DeSantis wants to
have it both ways here. He wants to be seen as a
great alternative to Trump, to the loyalists. And
in order to do that, you have to sort of appeal
to Trump's hardcore fans. But he also wants to
be seen as the pragmatic leader who can win over
moderates and independents and is willing to just
talk in a sensible way. But he seems completely
unable to do both. You can't be an alternative
to Trump. If you can't just acknowledge what
happened in 2020, you can't be the leader of the
future if you can't say definitively and clearly
the 2020 thing is over. Trump lost. Biden won.
Period. So DeSantis, I think, is going to need to
make a choice if he wants to actually have a shot
at this thing, which may he may already not have.
You either stand up to Trump and say, Listen.
We share some values, we disagree on others,
but we need to ensure that there's a future for
the Republican Party. We don't have that future
if we keep dillydallying about just saying what
needs to be said. We were beaten by Biden in 2020,
right? That's one. No ambiguity, no evasion. We
need clarity, honesty. I will never lie to you.
And the truth is, Trump lost. That's one approach.
It probably infuriates a bunch of the loyalists,
and therefore there is no chance that they will
even consider coming over to to DeSantis. The
other aspect to this is maybe what DeSantis is
trying to do is just avoid the issue of 2020.
Look, it could be calculated. It's it's not
about, well, I don't want to offend the Trump
loyalists or whatever, but he's just saying
I'm going to play dumb and ignore the issue
altogether. The problem with that is you're not
going to appeal to enough Republicans who want
a fresh start and a new direction. You're not
going to win back the people that Republicans
lost with all of this. Libs, if you don't very
clearly inspire confidence by saying I'm willing
to simply tell the truth. And so it's really a
problem for DeSantis. And of course, the bigger
problem for DeSantis is a mathematical one, which
is no matter which of these approaches he takes,
the average polling right now is roughly Trump 53,
DeSantis 23, plus or minus a couple points. And as
I've said before, simple math. If Trump already
has more than 50% of the Republican primary vote.
DeSantis can't win even with every non-Trump vote,
it would only get him to 47%. DeSantis somehow
needs to get some Trump voters to switch to him.
And I don't think this approach is going to help
him. He may be popular in Florida. He's not ready
for prime time. He's not ready to take on Biden.
But never mind that he's not even ready to take on
Trump. So we'll see if we get an announcement from
him. Latest rumors are anywhere in the next seven
or 14 days, 1 to 2 weeks. We may be hearing that
announcement from Robb to sanctimonious as he was
most recently called by Trump on Troth Central.